[Musica]
nessuno faceva cagare come lui e morì me
le parole foto chissà
ragazzi ma solamente un'intossicazione
da sito per ragazzi avevo cucina buttata
federa quello non ti preoccupare
no che non mi preoccupa ma dobbiamo
girare ce la faccio non ti preoccupare
abbiamo già trovato una rete le reti ma
quale qual è
[Musica]
lasciateci soli
giardino sono solo cosa stanno andiamo
in cucina
ciao ragazzi e bentornati alla nuova
puntata di cucina buttata purtroppo come
potete vedere oggi guglielmo non è
potuto venire ma ce ne freghiamo
comunque andiamo avanti perché il
programma deve andare avanti quindi il
cosa faremo
faremo una ricetta tradizionale con
questo piccolo arnese che tu che tutti
conoscete essere bello e sicuro lo avete
mangiato più e più volte nel corso della
vostra inutile ha detto questo andiamo
avanti e parleremo di come si fa
la pasta col pistola ok ragazzi per fare
la pasta al pesto avremo bisogno dei
seguenti ingredienti
andiamo a vedere aglio basilico fresco
solo le foglie pasta colta solo grano
italiano parmigiano un pochetto quanto
basta sale qb devo avanti pinoli allora
ragazzi il cileno è sparato
che si usi il mortaio
sono tutti a casa portato per fare
questa vita quindi andremo ad utilizzare
utero bonacina e chi semina il problema
detto questo andiamo avanti con i
procedimenti del buonissimo olio d'oliva
ai ragazzi di quelli buoni di quelli
liguri se ce l'avete mezzo acqua fuoco
ok ragazzi adesso andiamo affrontare
tutto
allora ragazzi cominciamo a frullare
tutto tranne il basilico perché la
rotazione delle dame potrebbe andare a
bruciare poi quella che è l'essenza del
basilico quindi cominciamo a mettere
dentro e pinoli in abbondanza che sono
sempre buoni era partigiano stessa cosa
e la pasta che lo ammettiamo solamente
un goccino d'olio per aiutare un po qui
il giro poi dopo andremo a mettere il
resto cominciamo lentamente a far
amalgamare gli ingredienti
capire un po d'olio
bene così adesso c'è chi piace a chi non
piace l'aglio giusto uv anche qui oggi
anarchia come guillermo senza dati senza
grammature senza niente ce ne freghiamo
ricordati i ragazzi a casa vostra fate
come un terzo dell'aio inseriamo
all'interno adesso il basilico mamma
ragazzi chiedo con il bel mucchio
aspettami non è ripreso quindi dovevo
provarla
ma dopo che ti fa figo dentro e
cominciamo a frullare tutto sappiamo
tutto fermo quindi abbiamo totalmente
che cosa si fa si aiuta con un bel corso
d'olio in questa ricerca nole non conta
ecco bloccate localmente andiamo a
muovere il miscuglio all'interno di
questa situazione qui siamo in bollitura
quartiere ok quindi adesso fra molto
poco andremo a buttare giù la vasta
grazie mattino dopo abbondante in questa
ricetta cioè sembrerà che io stia
sbagliando la ricetta al basale ragazzi
niente gugliemo resta sempre presente e
anche quando allora mi si è
completamente bloccato il mestolo
all'interno del programma era uno
scherzo conca parte gli scherzi come si
sta bene ragazzi che poi arriva il
coraggio avuto un'intossicazione da si
trovano da non augurare a nessuno adesso
neanche al mio peggior nemico
essere molto delicati
ma questo aggiungiamo un pizzico di sale
all'interno del nostro testo mi
raccomando un pizzico perché già c'è il
formaggio che è molto sapido il
risultato comincia ad essere di quelli
voluti a breve ok finito ha però ragazzi
come vi sembra
voglio giudizio vostro mammamia
complimenti buttiamo la pasta e siamo
pronti per finire il piatto visto che
abbiamo poco pesco noi andremo a mettere
poca pasta perché noi ci piace bella
condita tanto non ci dobbiamo mangiare
noi dobbiamo solamente fare la
dimostrazione del piatto un mucchietto
di pasta all'interno sono scordata di
salari nell'acqua della pasta sempre
poco sale grosso poco un'arteria di
marmo alla traccia userò il mestolo del
pesto per girare all'interno della
vostra tutti diranno che schifo ma che
schifo no non è vero perché i sapori gli
oli essenziali qua dentro si trasferiva
era sì ma tu non giri di trasferire
ricordo che si possono effettuare
effettuerà effetto è sono effettuerà
troppo della cottura 18 minuti il
credito guardare dietro al banco della
vostra pasta leggete il dato del
minutaggio della cottura del vostro
pastrone ovviamente levate da 12 minuti
prima se vi piace al vento a noi piace
un dente quindi andiamo direttamente e a
pasta cruda all'interno della nostra
puglia ma guarda all'universo è ormai lo
dico in questo giro
all'interno della nostra bull andremo a
mettere il pesto aspettiamo che la pasta
si cuocia e poi andremo inserire la
pasta il pesto da un pò di acqua di
cottura per far malga mare tutto giriamo
e via
qui i ragazzi facciamo come ci pare
forse non vecchiano quando andrebbe bene
una cucina bella piena di gente non è la
cosa più bella del mondo transare di
figo e fico pasta cotta scolarla
leggermente debuttare all'interno
dell'hub un mestolo di legno
giriamo guardate piano piano sta uscendo
fuori una pasta col pesto amalgamata
adesso un piccolo concetto di acqua di
cottura ricetta ragazzi semplicissima
velocissima con pochi ingredienti si
riesce a fare un cenno né per un botto
di persone hai fatto ovviamente un
albero di basilico e vedete questa
criminal agazzi io sono sicuro che voi a
casa riusciti a sentire l'odore però chi
lo assaggia ragazzi che volete prendere
la voi oppure passo io avere per a farci
perdere verso direttamente su questi
come kakà a gambo cellino ma ti posso
dire che io so la pasta al pesto di mia
madre che è un metodo che adotterò bravo
avanzatissimo della minkia e ci ha fatto
del canale
io lascio alla vostra lega cina ha però
usatelo possono dove si è cagato sotto
ma chi sei se ero stato io erano morti
scoreggia parte una cosa incredibile
ma proseguiamo la allora ragazzi siamo
giunti alla fine di questa ricetta
proprio mentre se c'è un po diverso con
i denti
mi raccomando iscriviti al canale della
corsa allora ragazzi mi raccomando di
scrivere minchia comunque sia i problemi
e i sensi perché stai musica per me è
sempre così fluido mi raccomando se
ancora non avete fatto
iscrivetevi al canale attivatela
campanellina commentate con indigestione
da sidone
alla prossima
[Musica]
colussi to me